-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with the fabulous
Wendy Williams.
You've been doing this 12 years,
on your television show?
-Yep.
-You've also been
doing radio forever.
Do you ever --
It's hard for me to imagine.
Do you ever get nervous
talking to a celebrity?
-No.
-Ever?
-What's the worst
that can happen?
-It's true. I always --
-[ Laughs ]
-I will say -- I don't kno
if this is true for you.
I sometimes get
a little goose-bumpy
if it's someone who was famous
when I was a kid.
You know, that I can't believe
that I get to talk to somebody
that I grew up looking up to
That's what gets me nervous.
-Agreed, but it's not nervous.
It's more like -- It's lik
when you were announcing
that I was coming out,
I was, like, a little mois
in the eyes,
'cause, like, you know,
"Wow. I'm part of 'Late Night.'"
-Yeah.
-I'm a guest on a big
late-night talk -- It's Seth
-Well, I think that --
-And I didn't grow up with you
We came up together.
-Right.
-But just the idea that you're
here amongst these people.
-It's really exciting.
I feel the same way
when I'm on your show.
It's really fun to be a part
of anyone else's
cultural institution.
-That's what I say.
-Yeah, it's a really cool thing.
-Yeah.
-You -- I've heard tell...
-Uh-oh.
-...that despite --
This is not an uh-oh.
-Okay.
-That you might want to one da
widen your portfolio of jobs
and include college professor.
-Oh, yeah.
-You'd like to be a teacher?
-Yeah.
-What would you want to teach?
-No, a professor.
-A professor, excuse me.
-With the glasses.
-Oh, you would wear the glasses?
-And the proper costume.
-Really?
-"Hello, students."
-Oh, that's very good.
-Mm-hmm.
-Yeah, I would think
professor right away.
-Yes.
And I would want to profess,
you know, in the latter part
of the talk show/no talk show.
You know,
the talk show is great,
but I can only do it so much
You know, I've got to go hom
and moisturize, Seth.
I can't be running
the streets forever.
-Gotcha.
-But I do want to --
I find that --
You and I went to college,
and I feel as though --
I don't know
about your experience,
but my parents
wasted a lot of money
on me being
a communications major.
-Yeah, well, I was radio,
TV, film. That was my major.
-See?
-Yeah.
But I don't think anything -
You know when I realized
I didn't learn anything?
Was when the pandemic starte
and I had to do all my own tec
and everything.
-Yeah.
-I was like, "Oh,
I should've paid attention."
But I didn't.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, 'cause I think
there were classes on everything
I didn't know how to do.
-Well, I didn't have
those classes because now,
you know, like, with the show,
they would do
the pandemic hook-ups,
but in terms of, you know...
"Stop saying 'like' so much,
Professor Eastman used to say.
"Stop saying 'like' so much.
-Have you managed
to stop saying it?
-I'm back to "like."
-Yeah.
I'm pretty bad with "like," too.
-And Professor Kosberg
would say, you know,
"You need to come to class more,
and you need to, you know,
do your thesis."
And I'm like, "But, Professo
Kosberg, all due respect,
have you ever been
on a microphone?"
She said, "No, Wendy.
I'm Professor Kosberg,
and I know what I'm doing.
And I was just like, "Oh, okay."
-When were you --
At what age were you first
on a microphone on a radio show?
After college?
-No, during college.
-During college.
-I was an intern in Boston
at Matt Siegel at KISS 108
-All right.
-Yeah. KISS 108.
-Yeah, I remember KISS 108
-Yeah, the internship was good
and Northeastern was good,
but only 'cause I made it good
You know, I used it
for what I needed it for.
But these kids, you know,
when I go to profess,
I want to tell them, you know,
don't ask me about what does i
take to be a talk-show host.
How about this?
Clean up your Instagrams.
You know what I'm saying.
-You mean clean it up so tha
there's never a point where yo
get offered a job and your
Instagram costs you the job?
-Yes, yes.
-Yeah.
-And where's your internship
-Mm-hmm.
-You know, and who have yo
gotten next to for mentorship,
which is different
from internship.
-Yeah.
-Do you know
what I'm saying, Seth?
-Lot of different ships
out there.
-There are a lot
of different ships.
-Lot of ships in the harbo
as you like to say.
-Yeah. Mm-hmm.
And money per hour.
That's what you're
going to have to make.
You can't just jump in and think
you're going to instantly
be this person.
You're not -- No.
One of you in this class
will be that person.
The rest of you...
-I feel like,
if this was the first class,
I would feel very,
I don't know, disenchanted
-Good!
-Okay.
-But I want you
to come back tomorrow.
-All right. Well.
Now I'm back on board.
That was very effective.
-Mm-hmm. Yeah.
-I feel there's
a real give-and-take
in Professor Williams' class
-[ Laughs ]
-You had a documentary about
yourself called "What a Mess!"
-Yes. Mm-hmm.
-Did you agree to this title
-Yes. I titled it.
-You titled it yourself?
-mm-hmm.
-And was it hard or liberating
to open your life up
for everybody to see?
-100% liberating.
-That's good.
-100% truthful.
100% -- Everybody who was
in the documentary,
including my late mom,
who passed away
since last time we saw eac
other, but, you know --
Yes! You know, tell your truth
This is what it's like.
This is like when I profess.
"Look, you kids.
[ Laughs ]
This is what
you might have to go through."
-All right. Well, I look forward
to more professing from you.
You're very good at it.
It is always wonderful
to be with somebody
who is truly
their authentic self.
Thank you so much
for making the time for us
-Thank you, Seth.
-That's Wendy Williams.
And "The Wendy Williams Show
airs weekdays.
Check your local listings.